zdf heute live herzlich willkommen die
kneipen haben zu die restaurants haben
zu das fitnessstudio zu nur die büros
die sind auf ist das fair ist das in
ordnung ist das sinn der sache und ist
das auch in ordnung in zeiten der
pandemie der arbeitsminister bertossa
hat sich heute getroffen mit den
personalchefs der 30 größten unternehmen
im dax und er hat gesagt hinterher die
bänder sollen laufen aber wo immer es
sinnvoll und möglich ist soll mobiles
arbeiten erlaubt werden und zwar sofort
er klang schon mal etwas mutiger sage
ich mal vorsichtig es ist ein appell
andere gehen weiter und deswegen stellen
wir die frage heute abend braucht es
eine pflicht zum home office während des
schattens arbeitgeberpräsident steffen
kampeter lehnt das ab er sagt das sei
unpraktikabel
wir wollen wissen wie ihr darüber denkt
welche fragen ihr habt die könnte
stellen an die adresse die jetzt hier
eingeblendet wird zdf- heute - live at
zdf.de und ich bin nicht allein wir
haben zwei gäste heute abend fange ich
an hier bei mir im studio christian
decker von unserer abteilung recht und
justiz im zdf schön dass du da bist und
wir haben zugeschaltet auch da geht
jetzt das licht gleich an laura sophie
dornheim einen schönen guten tag guten
ja sie sind via skype zugeschaltet ich
sag mal drei sachen zu ihnen sie wollen
für die grünen in den bundestag aber das
ist jetzt gar nicht mehr der
entscheidende punkt warum wir sie zu uns
gebeten haben sie sind managerinnen in
einem text start ab sie sind seit
monaten im home office und vor allem sie
haben den hashtag in die welt gesetzt
macht büros zu warum richtig aus zwei
gründen einmal weil ich wirklich ist
angesichts der aktuellen
infektionszahlen also sowohl der
ansteckung als auch einfach der der
todeszahlen die wir jeden tag sehen als
nicht mehr verstehen kann warum bin ich
wirklich alle hebel ergreifen um diese
zahlen um kontakte um infektionen runter
zu schrauben
und zum zweiten weil ich einfach absolut
unverhältnismäßig finde
wie das
komplette privatleben sozialleben
kulturelles leben komplett
heruntergefahren wird mit sanktionen
belegt wird aber im büro immer noch
eigentlich alles erlaubt ist das ist ja
das geht für mich nicht zusammen und da
ist mir irgendwann vor ein paar tagen
die hutschnur geplatzt und ich habe da
auf twitter mein beim ärger luft gemacht
und nach kommentaren gefragt und das
gutachten kam einiges zurück nennen sie
uns doch mal ein paar beispiele was
waren sozusagen positiv beispiele gibt
es ja auch und wo dachten sie war das
gibt es also auch es kann wirklich sehr
viel positivbeispiel ich habe mich auch
sehr gefreut aber es kommen auch immer
noch wirklich also ich meine sie
mittlerweile horrorstorys heute morgen
erst wieder eine lange mail von jemandem
sagt gehen sie in belegschaft von 50 12
leute sind mittlerweile erkrankt unsere
vorgesetzten kommen teilweise nach nach
kona infektionen noch nicht auskuriert
also pustend wieder ins büro
es gibt absolut keine hygienemaßnahmen
und das gesundheitsamt greift auch nicht
ein
und dann schreibt eben dieser mensch ich
verstehe nicht warum ich mich an
ausgangssperren für die kinder wieder
radios halten soll
wenn offensichtlich unternehmen und
gesundheitsamt hier überhaupt nicht die
infektionsketten unterbrechen wollen
ich krieg auch viele nachrichten von
leuten mit vorerkrankungen die wirklich
angst um ihre gesundheit haben die eben
immer noch ins büro zitiert werden
komplett ohne inhaltlichen grund einfach
nur weil der chef denkt im home-office
würde man eine urlaub machen oder es
halt so diese wiedergibt gearbeitet wird
im büro und wenn dann leute eine maske
tragen dann werden sie als hypochonder
bestimmt also das ist ja wirklich nur
einfach das viel zu große liste an spar
zu schaffen von arbeitgebern
jetzt geht es ihnen ja nicht darum dass
sozusagen anklagen dann bestimmte firmen
weiter zu reichen sondern sie wollen
insgesamt aufmerksam machen auf dieses
thema das sie offensichtlich ein großes
ist welche conclusio schließen sie da
bisher was ist so ihr erstes ergebnis
wenn sie auf das schauen was ihnen da
zurück getwittert wird also erst mal war
ich sehr überrascht wie groß die welle
jetzt wirklich geworden ist ich bin
natürlich froh dass jetzt darauf endlich
mal aufmerksamkeit ist weil ich finde
schon lange dass das thema wirtschaft
und arbeit
ja eigentlich ausgeblendet wird wenn es
um maßnahmen geht um die pandemie in
griff zu kriegen und ich sehe aber auch
er teilweise auch aus aus
regierungskreisen aus der politik wie
irgendwie versuchte abzuwiegeln und
irgendwie ich würde sagen ausreden zu
finden und ich denke dann muss einfach
was passieren klar die allermeisten
arbeitgeber handeln glaube ich gut und
sehr sehr viele auch wirklich
vorbildlich die unterstützen ihre
mitarbeiter wo immer es geht
dass sie so gut wie es geht im home
office arbeiten können aber solange es
so viele gibt die offen die da einfach
grob fahrlässig kann dann bin ich der
meinung ist braucht eine klare
gesetzliche vorgabe und eben nicht nur
so ein appell bitte wir gehen gleich in
die details noch wollen aber jetzt erst
mal das feld wieder ein bisschen weiter
christian dk wie gesagt auch sonst
abteilung recht und justiz es gibt ja
schlichte fragen an die man sich da auch
entlang hangeln kann was steht im gesetz
drin und was gilt in diesem pandemie
zeiten und ich glaube dass es wichtig
erst mal zu trennen momentan in der
pandemie was also derzeit gilt solange
wir diesen not status haben und das was
mittel- und langfristig vielleicht mal
geplant ist bleiben also bei dem status
quo habe ich ein recht auf home office
also nach deutschem recht hat man
tatsächlich kein recht oder keinen
anspruch darauf von zu hause oder von
woanders auszuarbeiten
es gibt also keine gesetzliche
regelungen die einen solchen anspruch
gibt und das gilt selbst dann wenn das
infektionsrisiko ebenda s also wenn im
unternehmen im büro das risiko besteht
dass ich mich infiziert
es gab verschiedene arbeitnehmerinnen
arbeitnehmer die in der ersten welle
also märz april mai letztes jahr
versucht haben das gerichtlich
durchzusetzen und verschiedene
arbeitsgericht in deutschland haben
gesagt nein es gibt kein recht auf home
office also wenn der arbeitgeber möchte
dass sich ins büro kommen dann muss ich
das tun das hat damit zu tun dass der
arbeitgeber einfach darüber bestimmen
darf wo ich konkret arbeite jetzt fragt
zum beispiel hier wie youtube pm uci
kann man home office einfordern wenn es
technisch möglich ist aber das ist
wahrscheinlich dass also selbst endlich
die voraussetzungen schaffen kann man
auch daraus kein recht ableiten oder
ganz genau so ist es also auch wenn ich
zu hause alle technischen möglichkeiten
habe meinen beruf auszuüben
auch wenn das zum beispiel ein
komplizierter technischer beruf sein
sollte wo man eine spezielle software
braucht und ich habe die zum beispiel
einen privaten rechner selbst dann kann
der arbeitgeber verlangen dass sich auch
jetzt im januar 2021 ins büro komme kann
mich denn umgekehrt der arbeitgeber
verpflichten ins home office zu gehen
auch wenn ich lieber zur arbeit gehen
würde also das ist sehr schwierig das
kommt sehr stark darauf an ob es eine
vertragliche vereinbarung gibt über home
office oder auch eine betriebliche
vereinbarung oder eine tarifvertragliche
einigung in dem betrieb in dem ich
arbeite
grundsätzlich ist aber so wenn es das
nicht gibt kann der arbeitgeber mich
eigentlich nicht dazu zwingen von zu
hause zu arbeiten also er kann mich
nicht dazu zwingen meinen mit meine
privatwohnung jetzt als seine
arbeitsstätte zu benutzen salopp gesagt
es kann dabei also rein theoretisch
denkbar sind extreme ausnahmefälle in
denen zum beispiel wegen der pandemie es
keinen einzigen arbeitsplatz aktuell
gibt in dem unternehmen wo man
risikofrei arbeiten kann und dann wäre
das theoretisch denkbar dass ich mal für
ein zwei tage dann nach hause geschickt
werden an japans soll schreibt wie ihr
facebook meine mitarbeiter also sie ist
offenkundig arbeitgeberin oder in der
position bei der mitarbeiter wollen kein
home office und beschmutzen meine schutz
anweisung was macht man da also der
arbeitgeber die arbeitgeberinnen die hat
ein sogenanntes weisungsrecht oder auch
direktionsrecht und das heißt sie kann
bestimmen wo die arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer konkret arbeiten das heißt
wenn die arbeitgeberin sagt ihr müsst
jetzt home office machen dann ist das
müssen die das nicht zwingend befolgen
weil das nur umgekehrt weil dann müssen
sie das zwingen befolgen entschuldigung
dann müssen sie das zwingen befolgen
nein wenn der arbeitgeber möchte dass
ich ins home office gehe das kann er von
mir nicht verlangen er kann nur von mir
verlangen dass sich im büro arbeiten dh
die arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
können sich im prinzip tatsächlich in
den allermeisten fällen weigern von zu
hause zu arbeiten damit das klar ist und
einfach auch klar ausgesprochen wurde
also ich kann nicht gegen meinen willen
das sozusagen machen müssen was sind
denn juristische gründe die aus sicht
der arbeitgeber gegen eine pflicht fürs
home office sprechen auch das ist ja
durchaus wichtig dass man nicht alles
was man will vielleicht bekommt und
nicht
das was möglich ist geht sondern dass es
auch aus sicht der arbeitgeber
tatsächlich gründe gibt zusagen machen
wir nicht also unternehmen haben einen
schutzraum schutzwürdige interessen und
zu diesen interessen zählt zum beispiel
dass sie die betriebs ziele erreichen
wollen die sie sich für das jahr 2023 zb
gesetzt haben und um diese ziele zu
erreichen haben sie die freiheit zu
entscheiden wie in ihrem betrieb wie die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer da
arbeiten und eben auch wo sie arbeiten
und von arbeitgeberseite wird daher
hoffe ich dass argumentieren dass es
eben jedes unternehmen als eigenständige
ansprüche hat und das ist immer sehr
individuell entschieden werden muss es
kann also nicht sein dass alle
unternehmen den gleichen regeln
gehorchen so wird argumentiert von
arbeitgeberseite sondern jedes
unternehmen muss auf die eigenen
bedürfnisse eingehen und ein
maschinenbauer hat sicherlich andere
bedürfnisse als ein software-entwickler
wo alle nur am bildschirm arbeiten zum
beispiel wir leben gleich weiter wir
wollen natürlich auch noch weitere
fragen beantworten vorher wollen uns
aber mal zahlen zum thema home office
anschauen und wie sehr
mehr home office für weniger
ansteckungen sorgt bund und länder
halten motto gegen die pandemie fest wir
bleiben zu hause
doch während kontakte im privaten
eingeschränkt werden müssen gibt es für
die wirtschaft weiterhin nur appelle
nach dem letzten bund länder gipfel
heißt es arbeitgeberinnen und
arbeitgeber werden dringend gebeten
großzügige home office möglichkeiten zu
schaffen
doch wie viele büros bleiben während der
korona krise wirklich leer im april als
die pandemie auf ihrem ersten höhepunkt
ist tauschen 27 prozent ihr büro
überwiegend gegen die eigenen vier wände
ein so eine umfrage der hans böckler
stiftung und ein halbes jahr später als
die zahlen wieder stark steigen sind es
nur noch 14
auffällig mehr als die hälfte hätten
laut ifo institut schon im sommer
zeitweise im home office arbeiten können
und genau das könnte beim anti corona
kampf helfen denn eine studie der uni
mannheim geht davon aus dass schon ein
prozent mehr home office die kurve
infektionsrate um ganze 8 prozent senken
würde
danach laura sophie dornheim der trend
wie wir gerade gesehen haben spricht
nicht für sie das potenzial dieser
zahlen aber schon genau deswegen denke
ich es wird hier einfach zeit wirklich
rechtliche rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen
und klare ansagen zu machen und nicht
eben nur diese bitte alle unternehmen
die die guten willens sind haben sich
längst an dieser bitte gehalten und
homeoffice möglich gemacht und zwar
tatsächlich auch maschinenbauunternehmen
ingenieursunternehmen alles natürlich
für die bürojobs die unternehmen die
sich bis heute weigern werden sich auch
von weiteren bitten nicht umstellen
lassen werden sich auch von diesen
zahlen wahrscheinlich leider nicht
überzeugen lassen
da braucht jetzt einfach eine klare
gesetzliche regelung ich finde eine
pflicht für home office auf jeden fall
aber bußgelder
falls eben ja fahrlässig leute immer
noch grundlos ins büro zitiert werden
ich sage hier noch ein paar stimmen auf
youtube board observer schreibt das ist
doch eine win-win-situation arbeitnehmer
sparzeit arbeitgeber spart
betriebskosten und auch via youtube
suisse man schreibt ja mehr home office
man kann im öpnv einfach keinen abstand
halten bleiben aber noch mal bei ihnen
vorbei
sie plädieren auch auf einen beweis
umkehr was genau meinen sie damit und
welchen zweck hätte das ja ich bin keine
juristen aber das ist wäre meine
vorstellung wir sind eben nicht mehr so
aktuell wie es aktuell ist dass ein
arbeitgeber einfach sagen kann keine
lust auf home office oder unsere kultur
ist es wird im büro gearbeitet sondern
dass wenn wirklich einzelner menschen
immer auch das büro kommen müssten
nachweispflicht besteht dass dieser job
wirklich nicht anders ausgeführt werden
kann
was aus meiner sicht die einzige
möglichkeit die uneinsichtigen da jetzt
am zu überzeugen freiwilligkeit ist ein
großes wort meistens klappt es nicht so
gut was sind ihre erfahrungen bisher
damit und glauben sie dass sozusagen mit
dem appell den heute ja hubertus heil da
im gespräch mit den 30 dax unternehmen
geführt hat dass das ein umdenken bringt
dass das ein bisschen bewegung in die
sache bringt glaube dieser neuerliche
appell bringt ähnlich viel wie der
bisherige appel
gibt wie gesagt ganz ganz viele
vorbildliche unternehmen wo das auch
super klappt und die eben auch
eigentlich allen anderen jetzt beweisen
sollten es gibt wirklich keinen grund
dagegen also es gibt ganz viele
unternehmen die berichten wir sind sogar
teile produktiver im haus ist auf jeden
fall sind die mitarbeiter und
mitarbeiterinnen loyaler wenn sie sich
eben jetzt auch von dem arbeits ag
arbeitgeber geschützt fühlen
ich krieg ganz viele nachrichten von
leuten die sagen ich habe jeden tag
angst ins büro zu gehen
sobald ich kann werde ich kündigen aber
ich glaube trotzdem dass ihr appell
diese unternehmen jetzt nicht umstimmen
wird da braucht es ein bisschen
drastischere maßnahmen sind wir beim
bußgeld sie sprachen vorhin davon
frankreich und belgien haben schon so
eine pflicht für home office im oktober
eingeführt aber man muss werden deshalb
dazu sagen auch da gibt es viele
ausnahmen fabrikarbeiter mitarbeiter in
geschäften und so weiter auch wenn die
unternehmen glaubhaft machen können dass
es anders nicht geht trotzdem wollen die
beiden länder jetzt die kontrollen
verschärfen und da gibt es bußgelder bis
48.000 euro schwebt ihm sowas auch für
uns vor einer aktuellen situation halt
das leider für notwendig ich möchte
eigentlich kein so auf nur zuckerbrot
und peitsche ausgerichtete gesellschaft
aber gerade denkt ich musste einfach
alles tun die zahlen runter zu kriegen
und deswegen halte ich auch mehr
kontrollen der arbeitsschutzbehörden mit
dementsprechend bußgeldern aktuell für
unausweichlich
linda ostertag schreibt wir facebook ich
denke dass ganz wichtig dass auch mal zu
sagen dass die menschen im übrigen im
home-office aber hätten das ist keine
freizeit oder urlaub oder sowas und
insofern gibt es ja auch da nicht immer
das gefühl sich rechtfertigen zu müssen
dafür haben sie das auch bei ihren bei
ihrer umfrage sag ich mal wie gesagt bei
dem hashtag aktion erlebt dass leute das
gefühl hat ich muss mich fast dafür
rechtfertigen wenn ich das machen will
es gibt ganz viele ja also wenn eben
vorgesetzte der meinung sind profis ist
quasi urlaub dann ist man automatisch in
rechtfertigungszwang aber es gibt auch
welche das ja einmal im monat dürfen
home auf das machen und dann gibt's
kontrollanrufe was ich wirklich
hochgradig absurd finde es mir hat ein
unternehmen geschrieben
es wäre lustig dass ich so dramatisch
wäre
unsere regelung für home office hat mehr
klein gedruckt das als unsere
werbeanzeigen ein unternehmen aus dem
telekommunikationsbereich
das ist leider also offensichtlich gibt
es sehr viele unternehmen und
vorgesetzte die eben diese veralteten
anachronistischen meinung anhängen das
nur im präsenz gut gearbeitet wird gibt
ja genug studien und gerade aktuell ganz
ganz viel gegenbeweise dass das nicht so
ist wollen wir hier nochmal nach um das
noch mal juristisch auch ein bisschen
einzuordnen also erstmal bußgeld das ist
ja durchaus auch ein thema das in
deutschland so langsam hoch kommt dass
man zumindest darüber nachgedacht wird
was tut sich da also ist so dass
hubertus heil der bundesarbeitsminister
ja letztes jahr ein gesetz vorgeschlagen
hat das eine pflicht oder ein recht auf
home office also aus arbeitgebersicht
eine pflicht zu home office vorgesehen
hat dieser gesetzentwurf ist erstmal an
der union also ein cdu und csu
gescheitert hat jetzt ein neues einen
neuen anlauf gestartet mit einem neuen
gesetz wo es um mobiles arbeiten geht
und da gibt es jetzt kein recht mehr auf
home office in diesem gesetzentwurf
sondern da ist es so dass man den
arbeitgeber damit konfrontieren dürfen
soll mit diesem wunsch home office
machen zu wollen
und der arbeitgeber muss dann innerhalb
von zwei monaten darüber entscheiden ob
das aber das zu lassen möchte oder ob er
das nicht zulassen möchte wenn er das
ablehnt dann hat habe ich als
arbeitnehmer noch mal weitere vier
monate zeit
und dann kann ich den antrag neu
einreichen das heißt dieses gesetz sieht
jetzt vor dass der arbeitgeber sich eben
in regelmäßigen abständen zumindest zu
der frage äußern muss man merkt schon
daran das ist eine langfristige sache
also das hilft jetzt nicht in der
pandemie diese zeitspanne
das ist mal gedacht für die zeit später
ganze wenn man das system sozusagen
überhaupt implementieren will sage ich
mal
aber das ist ja jetzt keine hilfe für
eine pandemie da geht es darum macht man
es macht man es schnell und wenn nicht
die firmen sich daran halten dann gibt
es ein bußgeld also was gibt es nicht in
deutschland ist auch nicht geplant so
was gibt es nicht in deutschland und die
es ist auch so dass wenn man sich
anguckt wie die diskussion der großen
koalition abläuft wird das alles zeit
dauern dh es ist auf jeden fall nicht
mit einer schnellen regelungen
zu rechnen sondern das was jetzt im
moment an an gesetzen da ist sowie die
rechtsfrage jetzt gerade ist so wird sie
vermutlich auch den kommenden monate
seien
ich habe die letzten zwei letzten tage
sehr viele zu recherchiert und
arbeitgeber haben wir durchaus dafür
sorgen eine schutzpflicht
und so wie ich das aktuelle gesetz
verstehen gibt es durchaus die
möglichkeit dass eben die
arbeitsschutzbehörde des jeweiligen
bundesland einen unangemeldeten
kontrollbesuchen macht und wenn dann
festgestellt wird dass da eben gegen
arbeitsschutz und aktuell dann auch die
gegen den infektionsschutz verstoßen
oder das nicht eingehalten wird können
durchaus auch jetzt schon bußgelder
verhängt werden das ist größtenteils
theorie weil es sehr wenige dieser
kontrollbesuche gibt aber die
möglichkeit gibt es meines wissens
aktuell durchaus schon aber eben nur
wenn sozusagen nachgewiesen wird dass am
arbeitsplatz die möglichkeiten nicht
eingehalten werden was abstand von
mindestens anderthalb meter anbetrifft
und was die üblichen regeln so weiter
anbetrifft richtig ganz genau so ist es
ist so dass der arbeitgeber der ihm kein
hof home office ermöglicht oder in nur
im geringen umfang der muss für die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter die im
büro sind muss er alle hygienemaßnahmen
alle cola schutzmaßnahmen zu 100%
verwirklichen und für alle verstöße
haftet letztlich der arbeitgeber das ist
ganz wichtig dann hören wir doch noch
mal was die arbeitgeber tatsächlich
sagen
das institut der deutschen wirtschaft
arbeitgebernahe das muss man wirklich
dazu sagen warnt vor einem wie es heißt
enormen eingriff in die betriebliche
freiheit hören wir den leiter des
competence fels arbeitsmarkt und
arbeitswelt oliver stettes gegen eine
pflicht spricht zunächst einmal die die
tatsache dass gar nicht gesagt ist dass
der betriebliche arbeitsplatz ein
infektionsherd den wir haben eine
vielzahl von arbeitsplätzen die gar
nicht ins home office verlagert werden
können
und da setzen unternehmen
verantwortungsbewusst eine vielzahl von
sicherheits- und verfahrensregeln um
auch auf gesetzlicher basis die das
infektionsrisiko minimieren würden das
würde auch die fälle betreffen wo man
vielleicht an außen sagen würden mensch
da könnte man doch was machen wo aber
ganz andere erwägungen beispielsweise
was die it ausstattung angeht was den
datenschutz datensicherheit angeht oder
sonstige arbeitsort natürliche
erwägungen das waren also sozusagen
jetzt die argumente der betriebliche
arbeitsplatz ist nicht gezwungenermaßen
ein infektionsherd und wie gehört die it
ausstattung oder datensicherheit sehen
dass hinreichende gründe das recht auf
home office zu verweigern
der arbeitgeber muss gar keine
hinreichenden gründe nennen nach
jetziger rechtslage sondern er kann
einfach frei darüber diskutieren wo
seine arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
arbeiten
es muss im moment kein grund genannt
werden wenn ich als arbeitnehmer zu
meinem arbeitgeber gehe und sage ich
möchte auch mal gesagt nein er kann
einfach nur nein sagen das recht
spannend ist glaube ich an der stelle
mal ein bisschen genauer zu werden was
wirklich home office bedeutet oder wo da
die unterschiede sind und genau darauf
zielt doch die frage via facebook von
micky caspar
was genau ist denn nun der unterschied
zwischen home office und mobilen
arbeiten mobiles arbeiten ist das was
jetzt während der cola zeit in vielen
betrieben gemacht wird dass man für ein
zwei tage die woche in unregelmäßigen
abständen von zu hause arbeitet mit dem
privaten rechner zum beispiel mit dem
privaten schreibtisch und so weiter
privat im internet mein wlan ganz genau
bezahle ganz genau so ist es
und der das entscheidende ist bei dem
mobilen arbeiten darf ist eben nicht so
sein ich arbeite hier zum beispiel jeden
freitag von zu hause sondern es muss
nach bedarf mit kurzfristiger absprache
einzelne tage müssen das ist darf auch
nicht geplant seien in dem sinn es darf
geplant seien aber es darf keine
regelmäßigkeit gegeben und bei der
telearbeit ist es so dass ich regelmäßig
manche machen dass dauerhaft also fünf
tage die woche
manche machen das nur in einigen tagen
dass ich eben dauert von zu hause
arbeiten regelmäßig und das
unterscheidet sich deshalb in großem
maße weil bei der telearbeit der
arbeitgeber verpflichtet ist die ganzen
schutzmaßnahmen die ganzen
arbeitsrechtlichen vorschriften die es
gibt auch bei mir zu hause umzusetzen
das fängt an beim schreibtischstuhl ist
der ergonomisch habe ich ein
computerbildschirm der groß genug ist
ist die beleuchtung ausreichend und das
geht bis hin zu arbeitszeiten die der
arbeitgeber nicht nur überprüfen sondern
auch dokumentieren muss
konkretes beispiel wenn ich zu hause
meine e mails abrufen und einige
beantworten und das sagen wir mal geht
bis 23 uhr
dann muss ich gesetzlich nach dem
arbeitszeitgesetz eine elfstündige pause
einlegen bis mein ex arbeitstag beginnt
das heißt ich darf in diesem fall
eigentlich ist am nächsten morgen um 10
uhr irgendwas beginnen das also ja
unheimlich schwer nachzuvollziehen ist
wie gesagt wer in der firma ist da geht
es noch aber zu hause weiß man nicht man
arbeitet der wlan aber auch da der reihe
nach dieser schreibtisch der dann
irgendwie ökonomisch sein sondern also
höhenverstellbar et cetera oder der
stuhl der gut sein soll der bildschirm
der groß genug sein soll
der sorgt dafür bezahlt dafür also kann
der arbeitgeber dann zu mir sagen sieh
zu dass du dir was für heftiges dahin
stellt im zweifel ist der arbeitgeber
dafür verantwortlich dass hier die
bestimmungen eingehalten werden dass der
gesetzgeber muss es ihr arbeitgeber muss
es im zweifel bezahlen so ist es also
wenn ich also nicht im home-office bin
soll wirklich telearbeit zu hause machen
und das angeordnet wird regelmäßig muss
der arbeitgeber auch dafür sorgen dass
ich das nötige equipment in
entsprechender qualität etc zu hause auf
seine rechnung stehen habe so es ist und
der arbeitgeber ist vor allem auch
rechtlich dafür verantwortlich dass die
regeln zu hause eingehalten werden und
deshalb sagen viele arbeitgeber die
solche telearbeit oder solches home
office machen die bedingungen sich im
arbeitsvertrag eine klausel aus dass sie
die wohnung die privatwohnung betreten
dürfen um zu kontrollieren ob hier die
regeln eingehalten werden das heißt man
muss ich auch immer im klaren darüber
sein wenn man regelmäßig von zu hause
arbeiten will muss man eigentlich den
arbeitgeber in seine privatwohnung
reinlassen
und wenn man das nicht zulässt dann kann
man sich später nicht darauf berufen
dass der arbeitgeber hier die
arbeitsrechtlichen schutzmaßnahmen nicht
eingehalten hat ich nehme an frau dr
das ist jetzt genau der punkt wo es dann
sowieso tricky wird weil wieviel heim
habe ich dann noch zu hause wenn sogar
der arbeitgeber dann zu mir nach hause
rhein kann um zu schauen ob das was er
bezahlt hat auch wirklich ordnungsgemäß
dasteht und genutzt wird also wie viel
wie viel zu hause und wieviel schutzraum
habe ich dann noch zu hause und wie sehr
verschwinden da die grenzen wirklich
zwischen arbeit und und und und heim
wenn man diese regel entsprechen sieht
es ist finde ich bin eine schwierige
frage ich finde dass da ist die
rechtlichen rahmenbedingungen nicht mehr
ganz zeitgemäßen also bei mir ist es so
in meinem arbeitsvertrag aber er steht
seit
anfang an dass ich arbeiten kann vom
wohnt wie ich will
weshalb diese täler arbeitsplatz
regelung nicht greift ich habe trotzdem
ein budget für einen ergonomischen stuhl
zu hause bekommen etc
jetzt gerade in der pandemie denke ich
hab es uns nicht weiter wenn wir dann
haarspaltereien betreiben und sagen okay
was das mobiles arbeiten was ist ihre
arbeiten da geht unbürokratisch wie das
ja auch aktuell von der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gefordert
wird arbeiten von zuhause zu ermöglichen
wenn die pandemie vorbei ist denke ich
sollten wir es generell da mal angucken
welche gesetze auch zum arbeitsschutz
von schutz von arbeiten
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern
wichtig sind aber wie die auch auf eine
aktuelle wissensgesellschaft in der eben
sehr sehr viel digital und von
ortsunabhängig möglich ist was dann auch
wirklich passt und wo man da vielleicht
auch neue freiräume schaffen muss für
beide seiten für beide seiten trotzdem
gehört natürlich dazu weil das sind hier
wichtige aspekte die dann auch bei
unfallschutz etc dann ja auch damit rein
spiel ohne jetzt man den teufel an die
wand zu malen aber es sind zufolge
fragen die sich natürlich daraus ergeben
vielleicht noch mal zurück wie youtube
chateau roubini schreibt home offices
cool endlich kein stress im büro wegen
lautstärke und das auto bleibt auch
stehen haben sie sozusagen neben der
reinen frage nach gesundheit auch noch
andere argumente für sie und in der
hashtag aktion gesammelt die dafür
sprechen über das thema gesundheit
hinaus was zu berücksichtigen wäre was
für einen recht oder für eine pflicht
fast auf home office in diesen zeiten
spricht klar also arbeitsweg ist ein
ganz großer überfüllte pnv ist ein ganz
großes thema da gibt es tatsächlich
darauf chef sie sagen erfahrung und taxi
das kommt auch von viel ist natürlich
auch eine große zeitersparnis einfach
jetzt und gerade auch für berufstätige
eltern ist es natürlich eine große
erleichterung von zu hause arbeiten zu
können und dann flexible arbeitszeiten
zu haben weil man dann eben das was
eigentlich eher möglich ist home office
und homeschooling oder home kita
irgendwie zusammen zu bringen es
zumindest ja ein bisschen machbarer wird
das wird ganz oft erwähnt
aber auch viele fühlen sich einfach
selbstständiger und sagen teilweise auch
ja zum beispiel der kontakt zwischen
unseren standort muss viel besser
geworden weil wir jetzt alles irgendwie
digital machen und nicht mehr nur die
einzelnen standorte unter sich irgendwie
sich austauschen
es gibt durchaus auch viele vorteile von
home office risikogruppe ist natürlich
auch so ein thema kommt auch von andreas
schleicher wie youtube die frage ist das
sozusagen eine zusätzliche option
spezielle risikogruppen er ins home
office zu stecken kann man da also
sozusagen auch einen unterschied machen
wen es betrifft ist das überhaupt
rechtens
also man kann als arbeitgeberin als
arbeitgeber kann man natürlich nach
solchen kriterien bestimmen wer ins home
office geht oder nicht also wenn es dir
wenn ich zum beispiel mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter habe die in einem vierer
büro sitzen kann ich die er in das home
office schicken als diejenigen die im
einzelbüro sitzen und es sind
theoretisch auch fälle denkbar wo jemand
zu einer risikogruppe gehört und
vielleicht einem extrem hohen
infektionsrisiko ausgesetzt ist dass
diese person vielleicht dann doch auch
eigentlich so ein bisschen gegen den
willen des arbeitgebers ins home office
gehen kann
das sind aber sicherlich absolute
ausnahme und einzelfällen vor drei
jahren jetzt ist es kein geheimnis ich
glaube man hört es auch so leicht im
hintergrund dass da auch schon mal ein
kind ruft das ist erstens die uhrzeit
sowie so aber wie ich schon sagte sie
machen ja seit monaten home office jetzt
ist es eine frage die immer wieder auch
in dem zusammenhang gestellt wird home
office ist das auch ein willkommener
anlass zum beispiel hochschulen gleich
mit ins heim zu verlagern
und was auch immer noch gerne in dem
zusammenhang gesagt wird die rolle der
frau wird dahingehend auch gerne
ausgenutzt weil das was emanzipation etc
über jahre aufgebaut hat wird mit einem
zwang zum home office gerade wiederum
für die frau auch wieder torpediert
das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen
definitiv ist diese pandemie für frauen
noch mal viel krassere ein shit frauen
das sind viel öfter in träger und
sozialberufen tätig und frauen sind eben
immer noch viel eher prädestiniert sich
dann auch um kinder und angehörige zu
kümmern
es gibt mit sicherheit den fall wo
frauen dann irgendwie eben nur noch aufs
auch zuhause reduziert werden es gibt
aber auch das umgekehrte das eben home
office ermöglicht dass ich es irgendwie
doch noch versuchen unter einen hut zu
kriegen also das glaube ich kann man
pauschal einfach nicht so sagen was ich
durchaus see ist krieg einige nachricht
mir sagen ja ich würde so gern home auf
das machen dann könnten wir beide home
auf das machen könnten dann könnte man
es irgendwie auch mit der betreuung
arrangieren aber eben ein arbeitgeber
lässt nicht zu und dann ist im
zweifelsfall eher die frau die
zurücktritt stunden reduziert weil eben
im schnitt man besser verdient immer
noch und das ist definitiv ein
rückschritt den ich beim top auf alles
andere was diese pandemie leider mit
sich bringt wirklich dramatisch findet
natürlich bin ich überhaupt nicht dafür
dass wir jetzt dauerhaft alle unsere
kinder nur noch zu hause betreuen
unterrichten und von zu hause arbeiten
ich hoffe sehr dass wir diese pandemie
bald überwinden und daneben auch wieder
zu normalem sozialleben zurückkehren
können was könnte ich auch heißt gute
kinderbetreuung außerhalb des zuhauses
gute schulversorgung aber jetzt gerade
sehe ich keine andere möglichkeit als
wirklich kontakte wo es immer geht zu
reduzieren und eben ja zähne
zusammenbeißen und zu hause zu bleiben
es fällt mir auch nicht nicht leicht ich
würde auch gern mal wieder ins büro
gehen ich würde auch gerne mal wieder
ein kind in die kita bringen
er vermisst die kita auch sehr aber ja
gerade denke ich ist die die alternative
nämlich infektionen in kauf zu nehmen
einfacher ist es darf keine alternative
sein bei all dem ist auch immer wichtig
glaube ich auf einen wesentlichen punkt
hinzuweisen und andere angelaufen
schreibt das hier via youtube wenn ich
das wort pflicht höre kommt mir was hoch
das volk braucht freiheit und keine
käfige
doch das hat nichts damit zu tun das
gerne jetzt irgendwelche schlagwort
sogar an der stelle genannt werden
sondern dass man einfach das gefühl hat
ich bin mir das nicht vorschreiben das
nicht möchte nicht verpflichtet ins home
office ist das durchaus auch ein punkt
wo sie sagen bei allem verständnis dafür
dass man versucht natürlich zahlen
runter zu kriegen was pandemie etwas
ansteckungen et cetera anbetrifft aber
das wort pflicht überhaupt jemanden
verpflichtend zu hause zu lassen das ist
schon etwas was in diesen zeiten gar
nicht gut ankommt weil sowieso schon so
viele einschränkungen herrschen
klar kann ich total verstehen ich bin
auch sehr freiheitsliebend und hätte
gerne wenige einschränkungen
andererseits diesen reflex zu sagen nur
weil irgendwas pflicht heißt es böse es
gibt auch eine gurtpflicht alle
möglichen anderen pflichten die wir
irgendwie akzeptiert haben
und ja nochmal ich kann es zu betonen
ich bin sehr dafür home office
möglichkeiten zu schaffen wo immer es
geht wenn wir keine pandemie haben jetzt
gerade wo täglich über 1000 menschen
ankommt 19 sterben bin ich absolut der
meinung dass hier so eine einschränkung
und damit auch eine pflicht
gerechtfertigt ist so herrlich schreibt
via twitter wie viel redet man mit
arbeitskollegen wo das dazugehört wird
hoffentlich maske getragen und damit
wird eine ansteckung ausgeschlossen
andere fragen wie viel arbeit gibt es
eigentlich dass menschen überhaupt ins
home office gehen können
tipp mal zehn bis 30 prozent der
arbeiten geschätzt aber was ist
sozusagen mit all denen die in handwerk
industrie dienstleister oder in
systemrelevanten berufen arbeiten
da ist es eben nicht so einfach also es
gibt ja in deutschland weiß gott nicht
nur büroarbeitsplätze sondern eben
glaube ich ein ganz wesentlicher punkt
zu unterscheiden auch nach diesem
schatten wieder was aus geschäften wird
etc
all das wo es gar nicht anders geht als
das menschen vor ort sind ist das
juristisch so zu sagen sie mal ein
bisschen schwierig das auseinander zu
halten was man selber so meint und
gefühlt hat aber eben um es mal jetzt
bei der frage auf dem juristischen punkt
zu lassen macht das einen macht es
tatsächlich einen unterschied oder gibt
es auch so etwas übergeordnetes wie man
muss ja das land am laufen halten
naja also prinzipiell ist es so dass es
jobs gibt die home office fähig sind wo
man ins home office kann die tatsächlich
einfach möglich sind und es gibt berufe
in denen das schlichtweg unmöglich ist
also wenn ich am band stehe und motoren
zusammen schraube dann kann ich das
nicht im home-office machen weil ich zu
hause keine motoren zusammen schrauben
kann und das ist sie also da gibt es
sozusagen eine faktische grenze an die
das home-office natürlich
natürlicherweise stößt irgendwann und
diese grenze hat auch nichts mit corona
zu tun sondern es ist einfach kann nicht
meine tätigkeit zu hause aus um ja oder
nein
schauen wir ein bisschen in die zukunft
weil ich glaube das ist wichtig weil wir
lernen ja gerade in diesen panini zeiten
alle enorm was so geht digitalisierung
etc wird vorangetrieben
nicht immer zum positiven aber durchaus
ist eine entwicklung und corona ist ein
turbo sage ich mal der vielleicht
entwicklung sowieso noch mal
beschleunigt worauf wird das denn aus
ihrer sicht aus deiner sicht
hinauslaufen wenn man sagt das was jetzt
sozusagen sozialminister heil
tatsächlich auch anstrebt welche welche
schritte sind denn da geplant für ein
ich nenne es mal recht auf home office
jetzt nicht eine pflicht nachdem
shutdown sondern für ein recht wie
flexibel kann das sein heißt das immer
zu hause sein oder heißt das ich kann
mir das dann aussuchen wie sehr kommt es
darauf vertragspartner an um da eine
eine eine gemeinsame lösung zu finden
auch eine einvernehmlich mit allen
beteiligten
dieser gesetzentwurf der jetzt gerade da
ist der aber in einem sehr frühen
stadium es muss man dazu sagen also das
ist noch längst nicht das letzte wort
was da drin steht ist sieht
bundesarbeitsminister heil vor dass es
eben doch keine pflicht er kein recht
auf home office geben soll sondern dass
es allein einen sozusagen einen
auskunftsanspruch muss man eigentlich
sagen vom arbeitgeber geben soll
das heißt der arbeitgeber wird
verpflichtet dem arbeitnehmer der
arbeitnehmerinnen auskunft darüber zu
geben ob er der arbeitgeber gerne das
home-office bewilligen möchte und wenn
er das nicht macht dann hat man als
arbeitnehmerinnen als arbeitnehmer auch
keine chance das home-office
durchzusetzen
also das heißt
rein rechtlich ändert sich eigentlich
nicht wirklich viel weil ich kann heute
schon zu meinem arbeitgeber hingehen und
fragen ich möchte gerne home office
machen und dann kann er sagen ja oder
nein also oder eben wenn es dieses lange
prozedere wie vorhin schon mal
beschrieben vier monate zwei monaten
neuer anlauf das ist mühsam aber soviel
dornheim noch einmal abschließend ihre
ihre sicht nach vorn nicht nur weil sie
in den bundestag wollen und für die
grünen sich aufstellen lassen dahin
gehen sondern eben auch als eine
politische diskussion auch in die
richtung gibt glauben sie dass das wird
fahrt aufnehmen diese diskussion weil
sie haben zwar jetzt ja für den moment
gesprochen um sozusagen gesundheitliche
pandemie etwas auszurichten und doch ist
das eher ein thema das auch in die
zukunft reicht und generell die
arbeitswelt verändern wird was ist da
das wovon sie ausgehen oder auch was sie
möchten absolut also bezahlt am anfang
über 50 prozent in deutschland arbeiten
im büro und mit der richtigen
technischen ausstattung sind quasi alle
diese arbeitsplätze alle diese jobs auch
von zu hause erledigt war
wenn ich mir die großen unternehmen
angucke wenn ich mir digitale
unternehmen angucke also die branchen wo
heute schon sehr viel auf arbeitnehmer
eingegangen wird aber nehmerin
zwangsläufig dann ist total klar das
recht auf freie office wird kommen ist
es nur eine frage der zeit
von daher bin ich optimistisch dass das
dass das passieren wird und würde mir
wünschen dass es ein bisschen schneller
geht das da die da irgendwie aktuell
noch bremsen und an irgendwelchen
vermeintlich guten alten zeiten
festhalten
ein bisschen er sich nach vorne
orientieren ich habe davor anschauen und
gesagt ich kriege ja eine mail bekommen
die anfingen mit die schreibe sonst wie
leserbriefe aber jetzt muss ich mal
sagen dass ich mir wirklich so freude
hierüber diesen unternehmen zu arbeiten
das eben mir alle flexibilität
ermöglicht und eben auch jetzt in der
pandemie auch seine mitarbeiter aufpasst
arbeitgeber- und geberin werden sich
viel stärker nach den wünschen der
mitarbeiter einrichten müssen und hat
mir von auch schon kurz darauf hoffen es
gibt auch ganz viele andere vorteile von
rom auf
zeitersparnis motiviertere menschen die
dann eben auch bessere jobs machen
man spart natürlich auch teilweise
kosten um dann ein büro am laufen zu
halten
ich bin mir wie gesagt ganz sicher das
recht auf home office wird kommen ich
wünsche allen menschen in diesem land
dass es möglichst bald passiert auch was
sowie don ein danke für ihre sicht der
dinge
das ist ein dicker danke für die
juristische aufklärung und aufarbeitung
schwieriges thema wird uns noch
beschäftigen
auf jeden fall ist musik drin und alles
noch so im schwange sag ich mal da
passiert einiges ja auch euch vielen
dank fürs mitmachen an der stelle zdf
heute live das war es für den tag heute
und bis zum nächsten mal schön anders